oh
[ __ ]
i feel like i'm in a [ __ ] simulation
half of the time where everyone is like
actually [ __ ]
thousands of people who were sent by
random youtubers who don't like me
would come threaten to kill me
make mock my dead father threaten to
kill my brother
threatened to kill my family remember
when trump's what was it or his parent
one of his parents or something died it
was ex-wife and everybody was like
celebrating so weird so weird even like
i'm not a buying supporter but if
someone of his died like why would you
why would you celebrate celebrate it
like what kind of people like who are
these people and why are they the ones
not getting censored like i don't think
anyone should get censored in the first
place but why is it this stuff that
congresswoman that was killed last month
in the past couple weeks she was killed
in a in a car accident in a really
tragic car accident and there were
people online first thing that they were
seeing was a one one one less trump
supporter and things like that they were
happy that she died and and they
actually believe that they have the
moral high ground and it's really
disturbing these people are so deep in
the matrix it's it's it's absurd oh i
think it hit the corner oh it's it's so
it's sad to see almost because you want
these people to have like an awakening
to how do you even show them at least if
they were truly kind you know it's the
kind it's the complete lack of kindness
that really it disturbs me that we can
celebrate somebody's death and yes
people on the right have done crazy
stuff too like when trump lost and they
rioted and all that like i don't condone
that either i don't know absolutely the
extremists on all sides but these are
these are average joes
regular people who were celebrating the
death of somebody because they perceive
them as a political opponent and they
can't look at them as if they were just
a human being who sees things
differently these same people on the
left that are that they're not
pro-choice they're they're pro-abortion
they're making like yes you can make
jokes about it but they're they're so
weird about it on social media they like
celebrate having abortions they're like
proud of it right it's like why why like
regardless of how you feel about it
let's not even touch on that today but
like i'd say i'm more like pro-choice
like i don't think the government should
be involved enough to tell you that you
can't do it but celebrating death but
but these people don't even understand
that it's something significant and it's
not something to be to be celebrated
like that they see it as nothing they're
so brainwashed that they literally see
how that you should celebrate having
abortions and stuff you know i think i
have the best take on abortion i think
that everybody thinks they have the best
take well i actually do have the best
take i think like after first like you
can have it but like you have to set
like a limit like these people these
like the left how they do with
everything they want to take it way too
far same thing with the transgender
people playing in women's sports they
want to kill your baby up to like the
point it's being born there's people
like advocating for that yeah that's
bonkers it's insane let's keep going
threaten to find me
these were the only rule infringements
on instagram things written against me
by other youtubers telling them to go
and do it while all i wrote is poetry
and and on repeat multiple times i said
on my stories if you're going to defend
me do it respectfully basically they're
letting the inmates run the asylum this
is what's happening put them back hate
doesn't beat hate it just creates a
brick wall if somebody says they hate me
explain to them calmly that they don't
understand the context show them a
longer format video show them how i
stick up for marginalized people explain
i'm a person of color and i've been
marginalized in my childhood
show them how i had a gay friend when i
was a kid show them how i stick up
imagine he was the leader of like for
black people he was the one that they
all looked up to rather than the
government and telling where they tell
black people that they're too stupid to
get an id imagine this guy coming from
south side of chicago one of the most
dangerous parts of the country if he was
the leader that these people were
looking up to how much more beneficial
it would be for society and for those
people of color rather than constantly
being fed that they're marginalized and
that there's nothing they can do and
that the system systems against them and
that's from the outside and even
internally all the super angry music
it's like what you eat your body shows
whether you eat healthy food or bad food
if you listen to constantly like angry
music negative stuff you're you know
you're held down and you know [ __ ] the
man and all that you're gonna be angry
it's natural you can't even get mad at
people for for absorb for being what
they're absorbing but if he was what was
being fed to to communities that uh that
are marginalized my god that would be
tragic for the government tragic [ __ ]
they would they would they would lose it
they would they would lose it the whole
black lives matter thing was to help
control these people and convince them
that they're like still essentially
slaves and stuff it's absurd for women
don't just reply saying you're stupid
you don't know the truth don't fight 300
people i was encouraging all of my
followers and all of my fans to be
respectful people even when sticking up
for me
once again trying to turn negativity
into positivity via social media my
instagram had no infringements
that was the only policy that was the
only how crazy is that literally no
infringement and they can just wipe off
whoever they want and i didn't really i
mean i didn't really complain to
instagram because i wasn't taught as a
person to go complaining to authority i
thought this is the internet that's how
it works just ignore it don't worry
about it soon the truth of your heart
and your character will come through
soon people will see the light and
they'll change because that's the way
the world is people often flip-flop on
issues this is how things happen the
redemption arc is going to be beautiful
i really truly believe
that within a few years people are going
to understand that i'm a force for good
in the world
and
often
people say
well don't have tate as a real male role
model there's better ones
where are they
there are no other male role models pink
tommy yeah no pink tommy he he's a good
he's a good one cry about your problems
yeah i'll be your emotional defender
yeah no that's why would you listen to
tape inspire the youth of men you need
to be aspirational they have to look at
you and want to be like you and there's
no other male role models that have had
the tenacity or the aggressiveness to
have such a fantastic life as i have
that they're going to listen to me they
listen to me because of my authority and
my authority comes from my life
experiences if my mentality is so wrong
how have i managed to amass enormous
wealth how have i managed to amass huge
social status how have i managed to
physically dominate the planet
i've done things that men respect and
they look up to me so that's why i can
lead them and i understand my messaging
should change in light of the fact that
i can be taken out of context but me
being alive on the internet will allow
me to lead men in a very positive
direction banning me and deleting me
leaves a black hole where they say
there'll be another masculine leader but
the men don't listen the youth of today
won't listen to anybody else that's the
reason i'm the most famous man on the
planet because none of these other
people have the authority to affect them
like i do it's me or nobody and i truly
believe that me
with reformed messaging now
understanding of my newfound fame is so
much better for the world than nobody
because nobody just leads to black holes
of who knows what and it can't be
controlled and that's where the internet
is truly dangerous speaking of instagram
i was understanding in recent weeks of
how these negative
fictional stories of me were gaining
traction and i wanted to try very very
hard
to counter them i put a post on
instagram which you can see here
where i explained that the things i've
said have been taken out of context and
just because i champion men's rights
does not mean i dislike women i think
that men are underrepresented in the
world today and as people often say men
need to speak up i'm here speaking for
the men i'm here trying to speak up
people are speaking up because of me
we're raising important issues in the
world today because of me
deleting me and blocking me is only
going to hurt men as a whole and
increase all the problems we see with
the youth it's what they want though
should we get free tate t-shirts made
and just walk around in them we should
make that a thing that would be dead
funny let's do it
people misunderstand me i'm going to
donate money to a female charity that
supports women against domestic violence
and i'm also going to donate money to a
charity that supports men's mental
health just because i support men
doesn't mean i hate women i love people
i'm a person full of love and i want
people as a whole to elevate not just
men or women i promised a dollar to each
charity for every like that's two
dollars per like total one dollar to
each charity
at the time of my banning i had 550 000
likes or something like that i believe
and if i hear from instagram what i
would like them to do is to clarify do
you know what the [ __ ] the left
people idiots do they make stories they
make they make [ __ ] instagram things
where it's like for every story share
we'll donate two cents and then all
these [ __ ] stupid girl i'm sorry for
my language all these stupid girls go
and repost it and they act like how
they're such activists and then they go
and spend six dollars on a [ __ ]
coffee and they don't donate a single
dollar to that issue they don't do [ __ ]
it's all a scam and they don't even care
about it they make jokes about it but
like off of social media all these girls
with the black squares they're saying
the n-word with their [ __ ] friends
it's all a lie everyone is capping on
social media it's [ __ ] i'm so sick
of it i'm actually this i've never been
like this mad at something online this
is even worse than like the end of 2020
with the trump stuff going on with him
constantly being taken out of contact
and me seeing through it and being like
all the stuff you're accusing him of
isn't what really happened i'm so sick
of it something needs to change we need
you just got the curtain just went up
for you this has been going on for a few
years now and it's really been
frustrating and difficult and i'm at i
i'm a few years in so i'm calmer about
it now because i'm watching the pendulum
pendulum swing back to normalcy but you
really just [ __ ] man it's it's we need
we need you need to be this is this is
why stuff like crypto is the future a
decentralized platform where there can't
be people at the top controlling
everything we need a decentralized
social media platform where people can
say whatever they want and people these
[ __ ] [ __ ] what's at the top can't
just shut like ban people like this for
spreading masculine there's good there's
a bigger beast beyond the social media
channels because do you remember when
they tried to create parlor the
it was going to be a free speech
platform similar to facebook but
freestyle apple probably banned it and
the um it was amazon web services or
whatever forgive me uh the name of it
and they they control the servers behind
all the channels and the internet and
they yours can't run and yours can't run
but they don't have the power to stop
sex trafficking websites that that no we
don't know where they are the dark web
oh no that's fine let that all run
because those creeps at the top do all
that like the free speech they have the
kids on islands and stuff these people
the same stuff they're accusing him of
and doing these people at the top are
doing they do the most [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you couldn't even imagine these people
are sick
let's keep going so that i can stick to
my word because that's what i am i'm a
man of my word i'm not doing it purely
just to post a receipt on social media
for real i was doing it because i
genuinely believe it's a good thing to
do
and i would like instagram to confirm
the final amount of likes on that
picture so i can donate the 1.2 1.3
million dollars that i promised i would
donate
to both of those charities independently
i would even be happy for instagram to
select the two charities and confirm and
verify my donation i'd be very happy to
do that because i said i was going to do
that and i'm a man of my word i stick to
my word what's interesting to me is when
i put that post up if anybody else had
promised to do that there'd be massive
positive attention but everybody ignored
it nobody in the media wanted to post
about it none of the youtubers want to
talk about it nobody wants to talk about
it because it doesn't get clicks you
only get clicks for hating me you don't
get clicks for telling the truth about
me
telling the truth but we do it in a
smart way because we get people to click
on the video first thinking it's hate
everybody ignored my charitable
donations if anybody else donated 1.3
million to charity i'd like to think
there'd be some sort of headline but if
i want to do it nobody cares and that's
very very unfair
what's also unfair is the people who
say that they care about women and
they're worried about misogyny and using
this
to attack me and try and have me deleted
from the internet they don't donate any
money to charity
they don't help women no they post the
stories for two cents that never even
end up getting donated you don't even
know how much of like the stuff on
social media is a scam until you run a
business that's based around social
media and you see these same people
running scams everywhere do you know
like how much of that is probably just
free publicity for some person to just
steal all the money like those instagram
stories it's all [ __ ] you're right
are you okay today am i just going too
crazy you're going crazy i'm sick of it
though because like literally nobody
people are so they their eyes are shut
they're not there's a lot of people
whose eyes are opening you're just
seeing it
at the big picture right now trust me
it's not as bad as you think it's bad
and it sucks out there but the good guys
will prevail the good guys like he says
are prevailing the pendulum is swinging
and he will prevail shit's gonna cry
because you can't you cannot re-enslave
people once they've been free i know
where you cannot take away our freedom
of speech and imagine he was in the usa
he could have gotten whacked just as
easily as they're just they're just
taking him off of [ __ ] social media
they couldn't be that way to whack
someone in romania either i mean this
dude is a basically a supervillain
living on top of a mountain with armed
guards it is much more difficult to
whack him than if he lives in a little
apartment where you know where he lives
it's just crazy like they they [ __ ]
could you know and they've done it to
plenty of people right now they hate
andrew tate when i'm gone they'll hate
someone else they'll find someone else's
comment section to go into insult
threaten their lives insult their dead
parents hate
hate they're not going to donate money
to charity they're not going to help
women they're just going to sit there
and hate me until i'm gone and then hate
somebody else this is a hate mob and
they're pretending that they care about
women they don't care about anybody
they're just hateful
and by instagram
allowing the hate mob to be successful
it inspires further hate mobs it
inspires further hate
further division i understand that
instagram and meta and facebook need to
as a whole keep their fingers on the
pulse of the national opinions i
understand that but once we have
confirmed that the national opinion is
misunderstood
then we have to sit there and go do we
want to bow to hate mobs which are
accelerating and encouraging people to
become more hateful for views
and to get people banned via hate
when this when these people may be
actually doing good things to the real
issue as a whole
is this a good idea for us to now bow
and bend to these people and this is a
really interesting conversation which
can be had for many many hours about the
internet about society about sociology
about psychology
about so many things this spans in so
many different directions is actually
very very interesting it's an
interesting conversation to have because
we're living in an unprecedented time of
humanity where the world is so connected
and we're all kind of unprepared for it
right it's very very interesting i find
it super interesting it's something i've
been talking about internally and i
would love to talk about more in person
and when i decide to finally come back
to public consciousness and do podcasts
and that kind of thing is something we
will be talking about because it's very
very interesting so he will be back
i'm teaching that it takes tenacity
and
toughness
to become a credible man of mirror and
value
i think even my hard
core detractors
would agree with me
if you're in trouble and you call the
police
you want a tenacious
tough man to appear
to help you
to protect you there's nothing wrong
with being a tenacious ambitious tough
man there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with strength
mental and physical
these things are used to protect people
protect men and women this is a
protective state you can't protect
anything if you're not strong
strength is a beautiful thing
the world is built on the backs of
strong men and i'm trying to teach men
to be strong again because it makes the
men feel happier inside it solves men's
mental health and it also makes the
world a genuinely better place
people are taking my lessons and me
trying to teach strength and
misconstruing them saying i'm trying to
teach men to be oppressive or aggressive
that's absolutely not the case and at
the same time they're ignoring my
charitable donations to the world and at
the same time
other media creators are
rewarded for purporting lies and
spinning lies about me and then at the
same time the media buys into this and
at the same time we're in the current
situation where this entire storm has
appeared where i've genuinely only been
a net positive on the world for anyone
who's watched my content in all of its
long form
i when instagram tells me and confirms
to me the number of likes on that post
i'm gonna make the donation as well as
that
the future for me now that i will be a
lot more careful and a lot more
selective with the social media i'll be
producing if any at all
is i'm going to be starting a foundation
the tate foundation which is going to be
dedicated towards charitable acts of
both genders
i have been very very private about
certain elements of
my personal life as has my brother
however my brother has a daughter
and she's beautiful
i got the earning a dog he's so cute
very cute
it's so funny seeing him with like his
little girl they're so that's so cool i
don't want to grow up in a world where
men are oppressive and hurting women why
would i possibly want that i want her to
find a strong man who can protect her
who can provide for her who can make
sure she's safe but i don't want
anything bad to ever happen to her
my own
personal circumstances regarding family
or something that are once again
confidential but i confirm to you that
the last thing i would ever want
is for women to be marginalized in the
future for genuine misogyny or sexism to
take hold on on the planet i would
completely and artly be very unhappy
with that for my own personal reasons
the tate foundation is going to be
dedicated towards helping men's mental
health and also protecting women from
violence against men
you're going to see
in the upcoming months and years
that i'm not somebody who's doing this
just for likes or doing this just for
views that i'm somebody who's doing this
because he genuinely has the capability
to help people and i believed i was
helping people via social media and if
that's going to be taken away from me
the sad thing is that him posting videos
is helping people in so much more of a
way than any amount of money he could
possibly donate to a charity because the
people what they do is they stare at
their phones all day so if you're
consuming content that's beneficial it's
way better than anything some charity
could do he's teaching a man to fish
he's teaching men to fish then i will
continue my philanthropy in other realms
please if you want to have more
information you can go to cobratape.com
sign up to the emailing list and my
emailing list is going to start
detailing all of my charitable acts from
here on out i'll be spending millions
and millions of dollars on charitable
acts for the rest of my human life it's
just crazy because even that that won't
have close to as an effect as what one
youtube video of him being motivational
could do but it does help yeah if it's a
good charity depends on the charity
he's intelligent man i'm sure he's
looking into it that was another rough
one then when you when you work with
charities in business and then you see
the behind the scenes of that you're
like wow well this is [ __ ] stupid too
it just just sucks
it's more money than i will ever
personally need i already was doing my
philanthropy through encouraging men and
if that's going to be destroyed then
i've decided to start the tape
foundation and specifically help with
financial aid women
protection from violence primarily i'm
in romania which is very close to
ukraine and there's a lot of problems
there with violence against women and
violence trying to and women trying to
escape the country
and men's mental health issues and this
will all be detailed on my newsletter at
cobratech.com and i encourage people to
follow my other charitable acts are
things that i haven't really advertised
or talked about i always felt a bit
embarrassed
to tell people about the charity i do
because when i do charity i think it
should because he's a geek i'm joking
not for likes but i understand now that
all of the media is saying i'm a bad guy
and i'm not even telling the world all
the good i do because i don't think
that's the right thing to do i think you
should just give from the goodness of
your heart we brag about our good deeds
you just do carry on and he's living
that it's crazy he literally if even if
he did the donations and made that he
would have just gotten demonized too and
saying he's doing it just for views and
clicks and likes even when i gave you
two thousand dollars in the last video
[ __ ] i didn't i didn't put it in the
title but people still get mad that i
recorded it i'm like bro i'm a content
creator [ __ ] he's just showing that it
works that's awful for people to be
saying i'm a bad person when i run a
shelter for dogs in romania because of
the stray dog
because of the fact that i just recently
rebuilt an entire orphanage because
there's an orphanage problem with
romania there'll be a plaque called the
tai orphanage on this orphanage and you
can see here messages of thank yous from
the children and the woman who's running
it i did this months ago before anybody
disliked me i didn't even tell anybody i
just rebuilt an orphanage and didn't use
it for positive pr
didn't try and put it on the internet
and get a good spin from it didn't try
to get likes i was just trying to help
people the fact that the only charitable
act i've ever advertised was their
instagram post so
i find it very hypocritical when these
hate mobs come and say i'm a bad person
when i'm the one who's out here spending
his money and time
trying to help the world you know what i
wonder because i'm a very calculated
person a lot of the stuff you see me
posting doing is calculated like stuff
you wouldn't even think like the dvd
player behind me a lot of stuff i do is
calculated so i wonder if he expected
that one day he would get banned i mean
i'm a deep thinker so i wonder if he
expected one day he'd get banned so he
did this stuff prior
didn't talk about it in case something
like this happens where he could bring
it up and you know seem like a better
person and i'm not i'm not even like
demonizing him like i i like the guy but
no that's just from a marketing
perspective of something i'm thinking
about yeah i'm not saying that's not
possible but it's not very relevant i
just wanted to but i i just don't get
that vibe there's no way for anybody to
know except for him but i don't get that
vibe yeah i don't think so it's just a
thought i'm not i'm not even trying to
[ __ ] on him at all or nothing it's just
because i i think very deep into this
because he could have just used it in
the beginning and maybe prevented the
banning also there yeah who knows though
yeah let's keep going and all they're
doing is telling their followers to
insult me on my instagram page which one
of those two things has a genuinely
positive effect on humanity because far
more people would have seen it the first
time around than now
however
i will stay again i do take absolute
responsibility because that's who i am
as a man i'm a personal responsibility
type of person and i understand that
regardless of the fact i believe it's
unfair i do have a cross to bear because
of my monumental success i've lived an
extreme life more extreme than most i've
been a multi-millionaire i've been a
nobody i've been uh famous i've been a
world level athlete i've started from
nothing to the point where i had to run
to the gym because i didn't even have a
car to get there i've done it all so
i've i've lived a very extreme life and
this is where these lessons come from
to quickly address the rumors that i'm a
sex trafficker and that's why i live in
romania
firstly that's a very very racist
attitude to have i find it strange that
the left and people who speak and
talk about tolerance and inclusivity
will as big as hypocrites in the world
media as a country will allow me to be a
rapist or that romania is the kind of
place where rape is okay it could even
cause they couldn't even comprehend that
them saying like something like that
could be racist to armenians they don't
even it doesn't even click in their
minds
that's saying something like they're
logical because it's so racist it's just
it's just insulting to their their
entire culture their logic is so stupid
and backwards that they don't even think
about that there can be racism outside
of like the
races that they constantly talk about if
i say you know if i have a problem with
the chinese government buying american
farmland because i think it's a politic
a political disaster to have another
country controlling our food supply i'm
a racist calling it the china virus
holding the holding the country
accountable for the reason that the
virus gets here he they're acting like
he's telling people to go but they can
do this yeah they were acting like trump
was telling people to go and chop off
chinese american's head no we're not
even talking about chinese americans
those were americans he was talking
about china one of the most corrupt
countries in the world and he got
demonized for saying that why why i was
saying the china virus is so bad they're
so stupid it's just if it came from
north korea could you say the north
korean virus or would that be would that
be a [ __ ] issue too yeah
oh
i'm done dude i'm [ __ ] done wow
you're just letting it all out all at
once and i'm gonna get they can chop
that up and make me seem like evil for
calling it the china virus they're going
to just remove all the contacts
imagine someone saying that the other
way around that in this country because
it's run by these people they're
inherently bad that's very unfair on
romania romania's been very good to me
it's a great country filled with
fantastic beautiful amazing nature great
food it's a great place i live here
because i love it there's no other
reason why i live here they're a
european union nation they have a strong
legal system just like every other
country and to sit here and say that oh
romania is where you can rape people
that's very racist and i don't
understand why nobody is pointing out
the fact that anyone who's saying that
maybe they're because it's because it's
a christian nation and you know there
there's there's a worldwide attack on on
christianity they can't even comprehend
that you can be racist as someone that
uh that's not a person of color to
someone that's not black dude there's
black people
and liberals that genuinely believe that
you can't be racist
yeah well i do that's separate though i
don't think this is racism though i
think this is another misuse of the word
racism and i think he's doing it wrong
here too i think it's just insulting to
this whole culture i'd say that actually
is more of an example of racism because
they're just immediately assuming that
him living in a romanian country and
being romanian becoming romanian is is
like romanians that's what they do
i mean it's just it's just a misuse of
the word whatever now what you're saying
about saying bad things about white
people no they're just white europeans i
guess i don't [ __ ] know but you know
that same [ __ ] racist [ __ ] no the
worst racist is just used for everything
nowadays and it's just misused and and
i'm watching him misuse it i think he's
doing it to kind of use their logic
use their logic against them and
politely throw it back in their face
but he shouldn't even bother but it is
tremendously insulting to the romanian
people to assume just weird and it
creates a stereotype of the of the
romanian people that is untrue and
unfair is
reporting racial stereotypes that's the
first thing
the second thing is my house was raided
by police under accusations that a woman
was being held kidnapped
i have spoke about this at length many
many times
i was effectively swatted i think this
happens to all famous people on the
internet where the police is called
happens especially in america they call
the police and say somebody has got gun
at this address and he's threatening to
kill somebody and the swat turn up and
it turns out it's fake it happened to
tim paul repeatedly it happened to aiden
ross just the other day being swatted is
unfortunately one of the things that
happens when you're famous on the
internet whatever troll did it you did
it you officially did it well we got
swatted yesterday it's so upsetting
just right after my mom arrived
[ __ ] man
you've heard of that right swatting
i was swatted
someone made a call about me which was
facing at least the police responded as
they should i would hate to live in a
country where the police get a call that
woman's being held kidnapped and they
don't bother going to look that's not
what country should do absolutely the
romanian authorities were exceptionally
professional i have nothing but positive
things to say about them they turned up
professionally
turned up and investigated as they
should and they found out that it was
completely false that nobody was
kidnapped nobody was held against their
will yeah tate gets raided by the police
now when all your other famous streamers
get raided by the police are they
[ __ ] sex traffickers and all this
stuff too no
i was not charged that's crazy
i have no criminal charges i'm here
against my will no one's coming to save
you sonny and people are still meeting
us saying he's a human trafficker the
romanian police are trying to get him in
trouble for human trafficking that's not
true that's not what happened and i've
said this many times but people continue
to ignore it and continue to report the
lie because that's how the internet
works right they continue to just keep
pushing the lie because it gets more
clicks or because they personally don't
like me and they want to use it as an
excuse to pretend i'm a bad person
i can sit here and be vain and arrogant
and say they're jealous of me and my
success and they want to find a way to
drag me down but that's beside the point
the actual point is it's not true and i
was swatted just like anyone else was
and if i had actually hurt anybody the
romanian police would have me in jail
because they are a nation a european
union nation with a strong legal system
and they would lock me up they have not
done that because i am completely and
utterly innocent they investigated as
they should and came to the correct
conclusion that there's nobody here and
this was a false call a false alarm it
happens to lots of famous people happens
all the time the person who made the
call about me
threw in instead of saying i kind of
think
if i analyze it the people who make
these police calls right the people who
do the swatting
it's kind of country specific in america
they make a call to the police and they
say he has a gun he has hostages
they can't really say that in romania
because it's very very unlikely it's not
likely to be taken seriously so instead
they try and find something the police
might believe oh he's an american guy
and he has this big house he has a bunch
of women trapped
it's a different story but it's the same
intention for the police to turn up with
guns and thankfully thank god nobody was
shot nobody was hurt they were very
professional very calm as was i very
calm conversations very kind everything
was sorted out very quickly
i was taken from my house
they came into my house at 5 p.m they
did a forensic search as they should
uh at 8 pm that scares me so much like
because i know if someone breaks in and
starts yelling like my [ __ ] first
reaction would be to go grab a gun and
defend myself so god forbid i don't know
it's police and i'm standing there ready
to shoot somebody and they're walking in
with the gun and they see me pointing it
thinking it's an intruder it's just like
i've never been swatted but i do think
they announced themselves they better
but sometimes they don't like that's i'm
pretty like the brianna taylor thing
that that that like i say it wasn't as
much of a race issue the girl got shot
through a [ __ ] wall i'm pretty sure
that they didn't announce that they were
police or it wasn't clear enough so then
the people were defending themselves and
that's horrible tragic
that's a horrible situation and then
they twist it into a race issue when it
should be a police matter issue you know
what i mean and train like training them
better it's like that doesn't happen but
then again i'm not 100 sure of the
situation because i wasn't i wasn't
there so but if that is what happened
those are my thoughts i'm not touching
that [ __ ] with a 10-foot pole because i
don't know enough about it like i truly
don't i know i know the broad strokes
that i've heard on the news on both uh
like political spectrums of news i've
i've watched about that i just know that
whatever it's hard to put together the
facts without watching all the trials
and i just know that during that time
period whatever happened to a black
person if it was from a person of
authority they would twist it as much
out of context and utilize it to their
political advantage as much as possible
yeah and that [ __ ] it was really
exploited the same thing would happen to
white people it would happen to people
in impoverished communities and you
wouldn't hear about that on the news or
social media at all nobody gave a
literal [ __ ]
it was it they exploited them for they
exploited them yeah they they were the
ones exploiting people oh my god the
same people that tell you that you need
to listen to them they're the only ones
that can save you that men can be bull
that men can be women these same people
want to want society to crumble they do
but if you're a normal person you lose
your job you lose your income you can't
walk the street you can't afford
security you can't afford to move this
happened to a normal person their life
would be over
it's scary okay it's happened to me and
i can deal with it but it could happen
to somebody else
and it's genuinely a scary thought
it's absolutely not really not true i
have no criminal charges there's no
charges at all against me i have not
hurt any women no women are coming
forward saying andrew hit me zero the
only video of me and a woman in
consensual acts she came forward and
said it was a game there's nothing on
the internet from any woman saying that
andrew is a bad person in misogynist he
did this to me not one it's just
misunderstood clips on tick tock
it's crazy to me that i have become the
face of evil with misunderstood
out-of-context clips on tick-tock with
no criminal charges there are very
famous people who have much more they
have genuine criminal charges there's
very famous people who have genuine
accusations they're still on instagram i
have none of these things none
i understand
that social media companies feel
responsible
for the national consciousness and the
national opinions and actions because of
their large levels of influence
however
i don't think it's fair that i'm being
vilified and blamed for something that
isn't true or wasn't even me
i
need to seriously analyze if it's
possible for me to even have a social
media presence for any longer without it
being weaponized and used against me
i would like to think that instagram
have their finger on the pulse of the
world
and that they're reactive and adaptive
regarding
how people view certain issues and
people
i'd like to think that they're very fair
and unbiased
and that they understand that in time
when the truth is shown
about my positivity and my positive
impact on the world the tape foundation
all the amazing things we're going to be
doing for men and women
over time they'll understand that
there's no reason for me to not be on a
platform i understand if i'm going to
continue on social media i need to be a
lot more careful with my content
not because i'm saying bad things but
because i'm saying things that could be
used against me
i want to dedicate this youtube channel
any other remaining social medias i have
my email list and my instagram at some
point in the future
to the tate foundation
and speak purely about the positivity
i'm doing for the world because in the
meantime and at least for the next few
months or years it's going to be very
difficult to talk bad about me when
people only see the money i'm donating
and how i'm helping people and i don't
just give money in a very lazy
charitable way i get all in my car i go
on the ground i help people myself i
drove my rolls royce to ukraine
i bought hundreds of coats and shoes for
women and children fleeing the conflict
i didn't film the refugees
i hate when people do that
so we'll be documenting that
i think that's a good way for people to
start to learn about the truth
i'm really relieved this happened
i feel good
i feel happy i don't think i could have
got
everybody's attention without this
i don't think i would have had a chance
to make a clean break and a clean start
and explain the truth of my character
and my heart without this
i think that if i was never banned i
would have keep
trying to tell the truth and my haters
would have kept ignoring it and kept
making negative videos about me and it
would have spiraled out of control until
someone in my family was hurt
or an attempt was made on my life any of
my serious fans who have watched all my
content know that i've had attempts on
my life before
way before youtube 10 or 15 years ago is
something i intimately understand life
and death
and it's not something i wish to revisit
i feel the hate around me was being
accelerated to a point of danger
for myself and my loved ones so i'm very
glad this happened because i feel like i
now have a chance to tell the truth
and i also feel like the social media
companies are very understanding of
their responsibilities and will always
reflect national consciousness and as
people understand the truth about me and
my heart their opinions about me will
change also
you know
the bible is full of redemption stories
so are superhero movies right the guy
starts off bad and then turns good or
the guy that you think is a bad guy
turns out to be a good guy with good
intentions all along he was just
misunderstood
i feel like he's like thanos you know
who thanos is in the marvel movies he
collected all the infinity stones and
snapped his fingers and killed half of
all life to bring back um balance to the
universe state
the most misunderstood villain except
she's not a villain yeah but that's the
thing like he's portrayed as a villain
and so is thanos but is really the
villain if he's ultimately helped like
trying to help i'm not [ __ ]
justifying thanos don't cancel me you
get the point human psyche is very
intrinsically understanding of these
narratives and stories
i think people understand a redemption
arc they can understand
when they retrospectively look back on
certain events or actions or words
and with their new understanding of his
actual intentions everything looks
different
they look back and go oh now i know who
he truly is i understand what he meant
by that
now i know who he truly is i understand
why that was said
and everything changes
i truly believe
that
this is a chance for me to move my
social media purely to my charitable
acts
even if my instagram is reinstated it's
only going to be about the take
foundation there'll be no pictures of
bugattis anymore sorry gentlemen
[ __ ]
unfortunate
not for the moment i'm joking and it
allows me
to conduct my philanthropy in the
physical world
as opposed to so much in the digital
world trying to inspire men
it's an avenue change it's a life path
change that god has chosen for me
and i'm happy with that
i really am not the type of person to
take these things personally
i don't take any of these decisions
personally
i'm a very logical man i'm very good at
seeing both sides of the argument
i understand the situation i'm in
intimately
i completely understand all points of
view
and uh
i this redemption arc this chance to
tell the world the truth about me
and focus on showing the good that i
have already been doing
before
these bands when i didn't want likes
when i didn't want clicks and also
undoing all the negative narratives
which i've allowed to spiral out of
control because i trusted in people to
do their own research and come to their
own truthful conclusions
i realize now that this is a fantastic
chance for me
it's a massive opportunity
i'm still going to tell the truth about
who i am about what i believe about how
i believe a man should act
i'm still gonna tell people and inspire
people to stay away from low quality
people
if you're struggling to find quality men
to be friends with maybe you're not a
quality man every relationship in the
world including friendships are mutual
because if you're a quality person you
meet quality people male and female
that's how it goes
i never would only talk negatively about
women i talked negatively about men all
the time
i told people don't have friends who
just smoke drugs and play video games
you need friends who are going to
inspire you to push yourself to be the
best man you can
i mean i'm a massive anti-drug advocate
the worst experiences in my life
revolved around other people either
taking or selling drugs and trying to
hurt me because of it i've never taken
drugs in my life i've never even tried
cocaine never tried a single smoke of
weed in my life ever
i'm massively anti-drugs but when i do
videos saying to men avoid men who take
drugs avoid men who are disloyal
nobody comments on it but if i say avoid
having a girlfriend who takes drugs
avoid having a girlfriend who's disloyal
people call me a misogynist it's not
about gender i'm just trying to teach
people to stay away from low quality
toxic people oh he don't miss he doesn't
miss
it's insane oh my this
i don't even know i don't even know what
to do what bothers me most about this is
that he has to explain it i know because
i watch a lot of his content so i see
both sides so it all makes perfect sense
to me but it's so sad seeing him taken
out of context so much and but even if
you never saw a lot of his content like
why do you why can't human beings make
the leap from point a to point b period
without without becoming turning into a
drama so they're even on our own videos
i see some comments i wish i could think
of a perfect example i can't where
somebody is saying something about us or
she said blah blah blah blah and in my
mind i'm like how how is it that you
can't make the leap from a to b on that
one do i really need to go that into
depth go walk you down and
feed you every tiny little piece of of
information or an ability to think and i
think that's part of the problem one
people look are out hunting for fault
they just cannot wait to find catch
somebody saying or doing something wrong
can't wait and second they're not
intelligent enough to make the leap that
if a man is saying men stay away from
girls that are drinking and doing you
know excessively drinking and doing
drugs and partying because you know
that's not a high quality woman that
that's going to help you get where
you're going the same goes in both
directions like why do you have to get
up his ass about that and call it
misogyny and even if he is talking about
talking directly to men that still
doesn't make it misogyny he can talk to
men about women you can talk about women
you can talk about a race you can talk
about a political party without it being
prejudiced and it's sad to me that he
has to even explain at this elementary
level that people can't think for
themselves it's sad and i actually want
to give a quick shout out to my discord
community um as that we were taking a
little quick break i went in there and
there was someone doing a live stream
who's an experienced drop shipper
helping to teach a bunch of people um
about products and how to make money
like surround yourself with good people
that's that's what i made this community
for and before the university even
launches people are already utilizing
this surrounding themselves with other
successful people and trying to benefit
off of each other and learn so i think
that's a great thing and if you are big
into becoming a better version of
yourself and success i would recommend
joining and just start talking and chat
joining calls i'm in them all the time
it's a pretty cool place to hang out so
let's keep going and just try and
elevate themselves and create their
reality to be around high quality people
and positive people male or female
there's no gender associated it's only
the fact that the media
these people chopping my videos up
whoever they are
taking out context and only focusing on
the times women were mentioned which is
a very small percentage two or three
percent of my overall content and
ignoring all the time i said the exact
same thing about men or the times i
loved women
i'm purporting this view and i feel like
this ban is the hard reset i needed to
tell the truth
so for that i'm thankful
isn't it crazy how even when he he was
saying the things like the man should be
the one if someone breaks in your house
the man should be the one risking his
life to go and protect you that that's
that scene is like a bad thing that he's
a misogynist for saying stuff like that
to me it tells me
like men
that we see that he sees the women women
as the most valuable thing in in the
home and he's going to go and risk his
life to save her and
this these broads are out there finding
it insulting give me like they just
can't like i said they just can't think
of enough reasons to be mad and they
like being angry and they like feeling
victimized it's their and that's why
identity because they don't have any
real quality those same women will never
find true happiness in a man that will
really provide for them and be a good
leader in that family and that's why i
don't want to find a woman in the u.s
that's brainwashed like that i need
someone that has more traditional values
and believes in stuff like this there's
plenty of them in the us [ __ ] man you
don't know you're not my age dude you're
living in
boston right at the moment the florida
girl like
i don't know the florida girls are just
listen i i know where i know where i
know where he look it's who you're
hanging with if you go and you and you i
guess i went to a public
like florida university where there's
just dumb bimbos
yeah exactly i mean when you're gonna
you're gonna be living at a higher and
higher higher level and interacting with
higher and higher level yeah men and
they are surrounded with and related to
young women of great quality so believe
me yeah they're there all right don't
[ __ ] on america no yeah no i've talked
to good women before this didn't work
out let's keep going but that was
partially also my own issues growing up
as a man you gotta mess up when you when
a girl gets off your lap and you say you
feel like flat stanley
what do you think's gonna happen yeah no
i've said some stupid [ __ ] all right
let's keep going but i acknowledge it
i'm a very logical person i know i make
videos of my faults i don't like to
pretend like i'm perfect i love let's
just go back to tate for a second i love
that he's looking at this as a blessing
that this is one of this is a huge
challenge for him he's been cut off from
his his lines of communication with the
world and he's sitting here saying i
think it's a good it's it's a good thing
and i and because whatever it is i have
an opportunity to grow from it and to to
self-reflect and that's fantastic now he
also and he's also smart enough to
acknowledge that he has resources of
money and security and family and
quality people around him that will that
will keep him you know he's he's in a
place where he can he can has the luxury
of stopping for a minute and reflecting
and regrouping where you know the rest
of the world if that happens to us and
we get the rug pulled out from under us
like that we could be doomed he's really
handling this with such grace and
dignity i i'm i'm impressed
what's next for cfg
well [ __ ] you as i've said
i have built my dream life
i have everything i've ever wanted
i've done that
with the tenants that i've been teaching
the people who
follow me
i've been teaching you the mental
fortitude you need to truly have your
dream life
i was talking to aiden ross on his
stream and he said have you completed
the game and i guess in a way i have
andy do you feel like you've beaten the
game
oh no i've certainly i've hacked the
matrix and completely beaten the games i
have everything i've ever wanted
i don't need anything else
all that's left for me to do
is have a positive impact on the world
i don't think anybody
truly wants to go down as a villain
maybe some people do i don't i wasn't
raised that way
i was raised to stick up men aren't
remembered for the amount of money they
have they're remembered for the impact
they have in the world like what else
does he need he's literally just trying
to help people and that's what he's
doing he's helping to cure people of
their depression give them healthier
mentalities tell them guys you got to
make money how to provide for a family
he is just having a good impact on the
world you know and it's just these
people taking his stuff out of context
and twisting his words to demonize them
that are better [ __ ] they're not
getting it you know i just i can't wrap
my head around finding joy in destroying
somebody it's really wild people are
horrible i can't people hate me on tick
tock
what am i promoting that's so bad i'm
promoting to make your money get
financially independent help take care
of your family and people [ __ ] hate
me it's these these people that are so
stuck in the matrix they're sheep they
don't understand dude you gotta break
out of this mentality everything that
you see on social media it comes with a
hidden agenda trying to get you to think
a certain way and do certain actions you
know you really got to stop and start
thinking about why people are portraying
the information that you see on social
media even this guy i [ __ ] i i think
very critically i'm like why is he
making these videos is it to to get
people to sign up for his hustlers
university like what what is the real
reason you have to think about it you
know there could be more than one reason
yes he's he's helping people but
hustlers university is also a business
for him
but if it's actually helping people you
know we haven't signed up i don't know
what it looks like i can guarantee it's
helping people though even if it's not
like the best information or it could be
better it's giving you the step in the
right direction even when i joined a
pyramid scheme i joined one of those 4x
pyramid schemes uh back in like the
start of my entrepreneurship journey i
can guarantee i that's not a regret of
mine it wasn't a good decision it wasn't
the best decision but it helped instill
mindset stuff into me and i learned a
big lesson from it that ultimately led
to my success and hitting six figures
like six months later you know what i
mean oh you gotta look at even how he's
looking at this like a blessing you have
to think of stuff of like how it can be
good and impact a good impact on your
life yeah twist stuff to your benefit
and just twist it much better just talk
yourself into it
really trick your brain trick your brain
don't think you're a victim trick
yourself into being a lucky individual i
sound like tate but i'm saying my
thoughts you know i'm being like this is
the truth like i've done this stuff
people
hate that i'm saying it because tate's
been saying it but someone has to keep
he wasn't the first person to say it and
he's not the last someone is he'll keep
clicks in your head you're going to be a
victim you want to be a victim be a
victim but you know to take other people
down is just being a bottom feeder
if i just listen to all the comments and
tick tock and stop making videos because
people don't like me they would be
winning i keep portraying my message
because i know that i'm helping some
people some people are listening to me
and they're like [ __ ] man maybe this kid
is is right he knows he's done the stuff
that i want to do and i'm not even
saying this to be cocky it's genuinely
just how i feel i don't know just finish
this up come on myself to be strong to
be commanding but i was raised to do the
right thing
and that's why
as i stated i have no criminal record i
stay away from drugs
there's a lot of people on social medias
with large criminal records who advocate
drug use
i think that's far more dangerous for
society than me
and once again they have
absolute exposure to the world
i
want to run the tate foundation
and i would
love to do it
without any social media
i will be detailing on my email list all
of my charitable donations all of the
orphanages i'll be building
pictures
financial evidence receipts
please go to covertake.com and sign up
to the newsletter it's free and i'll be
letting people know the positive impact
i'm going to be having on the world
the fame i've amassed has also managed
to help me amass hundreds of millions of
dollars
and i don't need all of it
so i'm going to use it for positive
causes
in regards to social media i need to sit
and think and work out a way that not a
single snippet of my words can ever be
used against me and even though i
consider myself a wordsmith
that is a very very difficult objective
to complete
and i'm going to think about how i could
possibly do that i don't talk like a
geek thinking any remaining social media
channels will be dedicated towards
charity
if i start a new instagram it's only
going to be dedicated towards the
charitable side of the tape foundation
i hold no ill will against any social
media platforms what if he just made a
new instagram account called like teeth
charity would they take that down
because they don't want him like
couldn't he just make a new account or
am i wrong it's weird that's i don't
know because if i get banned
donald trump lost his quote unquote
personal and presidential account but he
his i believe his i know all his
children still have accounts and his
company still has their accounts yeah so
yes maybe if it was that i mean why they
think this guy is the leader of the evil
and evil empire is beyond me w mom
people love you on tick tock hold no ill
will against any of the people who hate
me or who have tried to spread lies
about me
i truly pray for you all
i think that to be a person filled with
so much hate
that you think making videos insulting a
man and encouraging your viewers to go
and insult him and his deceased father
and his family members
i think that is a horrible way to live i
would never want to experience that
level of hate in my heart you're just
saying that yeah i know we were it's
genuine like exactly you got to eat
right now man we've moved on the dog's
eating in the background it's not the
end of the world we live here
it's yeah it's just genuine genuine
sadness like when i see people hate
commenting hate on my tick tocks i'm
like i feel bad for these people like i
couldn't tell you the last time that
i've that i've sat there and and cried
on tick tock comments that's not
something successful people do dude you
don't you don't sit there and comment
hate on people [ __ ] that's energy man
you're putting up bad energy and it's
going to come back around and bite you
in the ass you have to be a positive
person put out good energy and you will
ultimately become a luckier person and
have more success stop hating on
everyone's [ __ ] man it's just weird
you're hurting yourself dude the people
who are making endless videos
hate is never going to satisfy you
you need to learn to let go and live
with a heart full of love
you need to be content but with yourself
because if you're obsessed with trying
to hate on another person
the poison is inside of you it's not
inside of me that's what i'm saying
as much as it is
andrew i don't know if you're watching
this but for real man you've had a
beneficial impact on my life um helped
create our platform so thank you for
that and [ __ ] helping a bunch of
people you know yeah i definitely think
it's inspirational and [ __ ] all those
people it's such [ __ ] makes me sad
do you feel better about yourselves i'm
the reason your marriage is working i'm
i inspired you to send your son to the
gym i love hearing these things
and you can send me an email at the
email address below tate covertate.com
please send it to me i really love
hearing these things and knowing i had
such a positive impact on the world is
what's allowed me to ignore so much of
this hate storm that's been purported
my social media presence
is done is something that if it remains
will be created in a way that it's
nearly impossible to be seen as a
negative for the world
i'm a force for positivity and i'm a
force for truth this is the truth of my
nature and the truth of my name
anybody who wants comment or to reach
out to me
you can find ways to do that any media
organizations who would like to speak to
me you can do that through there's
various pr companies who want to
represent me there'll be ways of
contacting me
but i just want the world to know
in my final statement
that if you're a supporter of mine and i
know most of you are
please explain the truth in a respectful
manner
telling these hate-filled people that
they're wrong and calling them names
will help
these people are
not happy people because happy people
don't act that way tell them the truth
show them that the content is out of
context show them no dude all these
liberal liberal girls who hate tate are
genuinely depressed drinking doing drugs
every night they hate their lives like
these these people that are the ones
canceling them are the genuinely
depressed people you can't show people
what he's saying you know show them the
truth show them the thing they can't
even show it to them they refuse people
enjoy being depressed yeah they refuse
to even consider another point of view
because so many of these girls that are
on constantly online complaining these
are the ones that are like they joke
about their depression they're like yeah
i'm always depressed making tick tocks
about it is that the girls you want is
that the people you want to be like you
got to look at like the role models and
who truly has what you want and listen
to those people stop listening to the
[ __ ] of people who are depressed
always sad and don't have what you want
i say that a lot you know what i'm
saying what i'm saying i'm saying this
is the final part two one minute left
let's go the final part but almost
almost done long format content
say all the ways i've helped you
and i really believe by being a genderly
professional logical positive person
you guys can change public consciousness
for me
and
time is
a beautiful thing it's amazing how
things change with time
and in the meantime i'm going to enjoy
my fantastic life which i've managed to
build with all of the tenacity
and mental strength that i try and teach
my fans
you know how to reach me and i'll finish
with a quote from my late father
my unmatched perspicacity
coupled with with sheer indefinite
ability
makes me a feared opponent
in any realm of human endeavor
top g i didn't even realize that when he
was saying i'll be viral for a little
bit longer maybe he might be like he
meant like i'm sure he's going to have
to address his plans it's very clear
that he this was not his plan and he has
to wait
i love that [ __ ] too because i prefer
before i even heard about him saying
that i made my my three-step plan like i
still have my plan going on and i'm
still only in phase one phase two hasn't
even kicked off yet i can't wait i don't
even know what phase two and three are
i'm just along for the ride you'll see
that's worth takeover
all right well that's about it [ __ ] man
let's see if we got an email from tate
all right but before you you go you go
off and doing your own thing i think we
have to give to a final reading one out
of ten right on his final message
i think i think he he was fantastic and
in his final message measured reasonable
dignified strong
i think he's absolute 10 plus tate
initially you were down to a six you're
up to a 10. well thank you guys so much
for watching if you could like subscribe
don't mean the world to me join the
discord in my bio community we're all
helping each other out rough you know
we're all grinding here i still have a
long way to go as a human so i don't
know this can't be the end this can't be
the end um more of us need to step up
and start speaking the truth that's
that's what i'm going to make it my goal
i'm going to start pumping out [ __ ]
loads of content we're already doing it
we've been doing it we've been speaking
our minds speaking the truth we're not
worried about getting cancelled this
isn't gonna change this isn't gonna
change our mind this isn't gonna start
we're not gonna start censoring what we
say just steals my resolve to continue
to support free speech period just keep
it up g
[Music]